-A Republican congressman
accused his colleagues
of doing cocaine
and holding orgies...
[ Laughter and applause ]
...while Donald Trump decided,
in the middle of Russia's
brutal invasion of Ukraine,
he would ask Vladimir Putin
to dig up dirt on the Bidens.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
There's a lot you can say
about the modern
Republican Party --
it's paranoid, authoritarian,
obsessed with conspiracy
theories and culture wars.
But, in addition to that,
it's full of weird people
constantly saying weird [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
Like when Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
called the president the...
[ Laughter ]
...rather than
commander-in-chief,
which is the actual title.
Does she think the two jobs
are separate?
[ As Greene ]
Being president is super hard
because you're the commander
and you're the chief.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When the Constitution
was written in 1492
by Christopher Columbo,
[ Laughter ]
they were originally
two separate jobs.
The commander
was George Washington
and the chief was
Clancy Wiggum.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then there's North Carolina
Congressman Madison Cawthorn,
who said something so bizarre
the other day
that even a Republican senator
from his home state said...
[ Laughter ]
Cawthorn compared
the real-life Washington
to the Netflix show
"House of Cards"
and, in the process made
some pretty crazy allegations
about what goes on in D.C.
-The sexual perversion
that goes on in Washington.
I mean, being kind of a young
guy in Washington,
where the average age
is probably 60 or 70,
[ Laughter ]
I look at all these people,
a lot of them that I,
you know, I've looked up
to through my life,
I always paid attention
to politics,
guys that, you know.
Then, all of a sudden,
you get invited to like,
"Oh, hey, we're going to have
kind of
a sexual get-together
at one of our homes.
You should come."
I'm like,
[ Laughter ]
"What did you just ask me
to come do?"
-Yeah.
-And then you realize they're
asking you to come to an orgy.
-Yeah.
-Or the fact that, you know,
[ Laughter ]
some of the people
that are leading on the movement
to try and remove, you know,
addiction in our country
and then you watch them do,
you know,
a key bump of cocaine
right in front of you
and it's like, wow,
this is wild.
-Come on, man,
you really expect us to believe
that Congress could plan
and execute an orgy?
[ Laughter and applause ]
At best, I could see them
announcing
an exploratory committee
that would begin to investigate
the feasibility of an orgy
at a later date.
[ Laughter ]
And then it would grind
to a halt
because one faction would say
they wouldn't go,
unless the orgy
was carbon-neutral.
[ Laughter ]
And then Joe Manchin would say
he's only going to vote
for the orgy
if there was money
for coal in it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And then someone would say,
"Why do you need coal
at an orgy?"
And Joe Manchin would say,
"I guess you've never been
to a West Virginia sex party."
[ Laughter ]
It just wouldn't happen.
Although --
although, in Cawthorn's defense,
I will say Chuck Schumer
positions his glasses
like a man watching an orgy.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Schumer ]
Well, well, well.
What do we have here?
[ Laughter ]
Also, I got to say, if they were
having orgies and doing cocaine,
I would actually find
that impressive.
I mean, they're all 70
and 80 years old.
If you told me Chuck Grassley
was snorting blow
and boning nonstop,
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'd be like, "Damn!
Maybe he's more with it
than I thought."
[ Laughter ]
Also, Chuck Grassley,
just going to say it --
pretty good name
for an adult film star.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Grassley ]
Did somebody order a pizza?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, Cawthorn
is presumably referring
to his fellow Republicans here,
since those are the people
he caucuses
and spends time with.
So, he seems to be accusing
his own GOP colleagues
of being sex-crazed
drug addicts,
which is why, understandably,
those same colleagues
are pissed at him now.
House GOP Leader
Kevin McCarthy
called Cawthorn
in to his office today,
maybe hoping to score an invite
or to tell him to stop narcing;
[ Laughter ]
and Pennsylvania Republican
Scott Perry, the chairman
of the ultra conservative
House Freedom Caucus...
[ Laughter ]
Oh, please don't name names.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Because all those names go
with faces we know.
[ Laughter ]
But this is truly
an amazing turn
in the evolution
of the Republican Party.
They whipped up their base
into believing crazy [bleep]
That base then elected
a bunch of crazy people
who believe that crazy [bleep]
and, now, those crazy people
are accusing
their fellow Republicans
of engaging
in wild,
drug-fueled sex parties.
This whole group
of pro-Trump toadies
is just so weird and loathsome,
like Texas Senator Ted Cruz,
for example, who --
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to go
out on a limb here --
wasn't invited to the orgy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Cruz ]
Well, it's just frustrating
because we're always getting
our dates mixed up.
[ Laughter ]
Cruz claimed, the other day,
that a mysterious cabal
is, somehow, controlling
the Biden administration
because he personally
has not spoken to Biden
during his presidency.
-I actually get asked that
almost every day.
Somebody says,
"Who's really running things?"
And let me tell you,
the scary thing?
I have no idea.
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
So Biden's been president,
what, 15 months?
In that entire time,
I have not spoken with him once.
-Well, I guess that means he's
at the orgies
that you're not at.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I do wonder why a person
wouldn't want to speak
to Ted Cruz.
It truly is a mystery.
It's one of those
age old questions.
Why don't people like talking
to Ted Cruz
or why don't people like getting
hit in the nuts with a football?
[ Laughter ]
This is the modern
Republican Party --
a collection of fringe weirdos
who, by the way,
will very likely control
Congress next year
and they could very well
end up nominating
Donald Trump
for president again.
He keeps holding
his unhinged rallies
and keeps strongly hinting
that he'll run again
and he remains, as of now,
the most influential Republican
in the country,
which is terrifying
for many reasons,
among which is the fact
that he tried to stage a coup,
which a House committee
and a federal judge
have said
was very likely a crime.
He's hidden,
or possibly even destroyed,
evidence of that crime.
And, on top of all that,
keeps going out of his way
to praise a brutal autocrat
currently waging a horrific war
on an innocent
neighboring country.
And now, Trump is complaining
that the media keeps getting mad
whenever he calls
various dictators,
like Vladimir Putin, smart.
-You know, every time I say
somebody's smart,
they always go, "Oh!
Trump said that President Xi
of China is smart!"
Well, you know,
he runs 1.5 billion people
with an iron fist.
Yeah, I think he's pretty smart.
[ Laughter ]
And they have a chain
over there.
You know, if you're a dummy,
you get left here.
It's like this.
It's like a pyramid.
The smartest one gets
to the top.
But they ask me,
"Is Putin smart?"
Yes, Putin was smart
and I actually thought
he was going to be negotiating.
I said, "That's a hell
of a way to negotiate --
put 200,000 soldiers
on the border."
It looked like
a great negotiation.
That didn't work out
too well for him.
-I like wounded Trump.
He's 75, but whines like
a grounded teenager.
[ As Trump ]
It's not fair.
Everyone's mad at me
[ Laughter ]
because I said Putin's smart.
I said he's smart
for dumping Sarah
and taking the head
cheerleader to prom.
And, sure, Sarah is perfect
for Vlad. We all know that.
But the head cheerleader's
hotter!
[ Laughter ]
Well, maybe, one day, Sarah will
take off those glasses.
[ Laughter ]
Also, what do you mean,
it was a great negotiation
that didn't work out
too well for him?
How can both of those
things be true?
[ Laughter ]
I cannot believe this guy
was commander or chief.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Of course, as the world watches
the conflict in Ukraine
with horror,
most decent, compassionate
people are asking themselves
what they can do to help,
while responsible
world leaders try
to come up with solutions
to end the crisis.
Russian and Ukrainian
negotiators have been meeting
to try to hash out
a ceasefire, a peace deal.
And then there's Trump,
who apparently thought now
would be a good time, in the
middle of a monstrous war,
to pitch some ideas
to Vladimir Putin
on how he could help Trump out
and weaken Joe Biden.
-As long as Putin, now, is not
exactly a fan of our country,
let him explain where did --
Because Chris Wallace wouldn't
let me ask the question.
Why did the mayor
of Moscow's wife
give the Bidens --
both of them --
$3.5 million?
That's a lot of money.
She gave them $3.5 million.
So, now, I would think Putin
would know the answer to that.
I think he should release it.
I think we should know
that answer.
I think Putin, now,
would be willing
to probably give that answer.
I'm sure he knows.
-It's so shocking and gross,
I need a second to process it,
which brings us
to a segment called
"Seth Needs a Smoke Break."
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I mean, damn, man.
I don't smoke.
This is disgusting.
[ Laughter and applause ]
People do that?
[ Laughter ]
This has been
"Seth Needs a Smoke Break."
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
You can always --
You can always count on Trump
to have both the worst
and most insane take
on any topic.
I'd be terrified to hear
what he thought of the Oscars.
[ As Trump ]
If anything, I think
we could've used
one or maybe two more slaps.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, you know -- And, you know,
it's never the slapper's fault.
It's the slapee
because you have to be ready.
You have to be ready.
[ Laughter ]
That's why I was always
practicing karate
at my press conferences.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You have to scare off
potential slappers.
[ Laughter ]
Second, you're accusing
someone else
of taking money from Russia?
You repeatedly tried
to do business deals in Moscow,
including while you were
running for president,
when you signed
a letter of intent
to build a Trump Tower
in Moscow.
CNN even obtained a copy
of the official letter of intent
from October 2015
and it had your signature on it.
And we know it's your signature
because it was in Sharpie
and it looks like the results
of a cardiogram
from a patient in the middle
of a heart attack.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Look at that.
It looks like a New Yorker
cartoon of a Klan rally.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you looked at that signature
without knowing who it was,
you'd think the name was
Ahhhhhhh!
[ Laughter ]
These two moments should
give you a pretty good idea
of where the Republican Party
is right now.
It's an unhinged movement
of aspiring authoritarians
whose leader is openly
praising a brutal tyrant
and asking him, once again,
to intervene in U.S. politics,
while a congressman
accuses his colleagues
of drug-fueled sex parties.
I have no idea what those orgies
look like, but I'm guessing...
-It's like a pyramid.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.